And keys to your heart?
Well, no, they're actually all the keys to the time machines that I have at home.
Great! And what is that?
The lock in the diary?
Well, this is a Tamagotchi.
It's been my tech contribution for this year's Met Gala.
It's humble but it's tech.
I love your eye makeup and I love your dark lips.
I dyed my brows about 45 minutes ago.
Oh, how brilliant!
My stylist Leslie was having a panic attack.
Had to drink two tequilas, she's just like, "What are you doing?"
I'm like, "Trust me, trust me, trust me."
I love this.
Thank you very much.
You had this already or it came tonight?
No, it came tonight, it's all custom.
Prada!
Love the gloves.
Thank you.
Are you gonna have fun?
I'm gonna have fun. I'm gonna have a ball.
A ball?
That's right.
Have fun!